hello freak [ __ ] how did you get so
how did you get the Alex Jones 1 to be
911 do I to fit some podcasts in I had
to do like extra ones the week before
just so I could get to number 911 with
Alex yeah that sounds like a long see
that so I could've had him on earlier
and I would have definitely had him on
again for 911 but having one the first
time for 911 and to this day that's our
biggest podcast by really far by maybe 5
million downloads [ __ ] yeah but here's
the conspiracy rise up right am i saying
correctly what is the actual number it
was like said prior 16 now I didn't
check in the last two or three days but
okay so it's 16 million dot here's
what's crazy
it never charted on iTunes the iTunes
charts magically went down while the
Alex Jones podcast was in the queue and
they stayed down for over a week
conspiracy theory and then when it came
back up podcast that got way less
downloads than Alex's were r-rated much
higher than his and they had happened
before and after I do remember his was
the only podcast that was left out of
the ratings loop like for sure would
have been the number one podcast in the
country it was the number one podcast we
did by a mile and I had the number one
podcast before it's like number one
podcast episode that was more than 5
million downloads more than any other
podcast I had before so it's for sure
probably would have been number one it
was a lot of downloads unless they had
like one of those serial episodes or
something that came up that week OS town
mmm so there you go and that's it's it's
very likely that someone's trying to
hold Alex Jones back and that just
Stokes his [ __ ] fire they don't
understand it's a Streisand effect can
still fire of Alex Jones even Megyn
Kelly's [ __ ] now her show's going down
the toilet is it what happened in the
aftermath she hears that here's the
problem here's a problem
Meghan Kelly was a Fox News person she
left fox news to go to NBC NBC is
thought of as CNBC which is thought of
as fake news by these right-wing Trump
Trump bands what would you call them
Trump Trump errs so as soon as she goes
over there they're not gonna listen to
and then to the Liberals she's Fox News
right so if they're not interested in
her either and then she does this
podcast with Alex Jones or this
interview rather with Alex Jones and the
interview with Alex Jones she says I'm
not gonna paint you out as a monster I'm
gonna give you a fair look she's saying
all these things that she's gonna throw
softballs this way I want people to get
to know you and he releases all that
he's like hey this is that person and
the ratings just keep you got if you
want to be an ice princess yeah go box
news full life if you want you want to
sell guns you want to be a Second
Amendment for pronet with cold blue
steel eyes and then smooth shiny legs
and nice shoes and tiny skirts yeah you
Squarepants are the oil them up - yeah
of illegal immigrants how do you do it
then it's just kind of natural thing for
me
oh really you're hairless and the legs
somebody's gotta be like that I got me
some money out there with no leg hair
I'm sure it happens it's called purity
yeah sure what it's called sure has been
you brought it up
[Applause]
[Music]